you had a rare
leukemia
due to
all the work that you did at ground zero
can you maybe talk to
the experience of just breathing through
those days
and what that was like being unable to
breathe
being overwhelmed by all of the dust in
the air
yes um the the first day especially
um we
we didn't have equipment we ran you know
we didn't have breathing apparatus and
then we were handed little 69
hardware store dust mask you know those
little thin paint masks that would just
get sweated up and fit you know sticking
to your face within 30 seconds so you
would you just they were useless
and what what you wound up feeling like
was that you you swallowed a box of
razor blades because there was glass and
there was cement and it was just so
caustic
and uh
i remember that night you know when we
went back just to get some medical
relief uh for the few hours
we were walking up the hill to the
firehouse because they dropped us off
like a block
away down at engine 201s and quarters
and uh
one of the older firemen and as we're
walking up the block we're all
struggling we're all having a hard time
breathing and just just i mean i felt
like i was dying literally it's it was
pretty bad and just remember the one guy
going now we're all dead and i said no
no we made it we made it he goes no you
don't get a kid he said
we just breathed in poison after poison
for for hours and then that went into
days and it went into months
he says we're all dead men this is going
to take us all
and i i i thought he was crazy and then
now years later like starting in 0.304
guys just started coming down with he's
really rare and advanced cancers and
then
it just it just stopped being a
coincidence
with the number of guys and they were
young one one of the first guys john
mcnamara he was 33 or 34 and he came
down
colon cancer and it took him quickly in
2000
it was in 2005 and
i i kind of said to you know
friends and family i said i feel like
i'm running through a minefield and i
wonder when my i'm going to step on my
mind because everybody's going to get
sick
and i wasn't feeling well from 2008 on
just i just i couldn't put it and i
couldn't put my finger on it but i just
wasn't right
and in 2011
uh
i i failed my medical uh my bloods my
bloods came back horrifically wrong
and they pulled me off the truck
but uh they strung me out for a month
the
doctors in the fire department one of
them said my spleen was engorged because
it was probably drinking myself the
death lake
as he said most of the guys
did after 9 11
which was pretty wrong of him in
stereotypical you know just just to
stereotype and to categorize and
guy couldn't have cared less he just he
was so crude and nasty and then my one
doctor who was my doctor on the outside
my blood pressure was 240 over 140
my spleen was about to rupture
she didn't even show up for my
appointment and i went down i passed out
the paramedics responded
she got into an argument with a
paramedic because for big ego and
basically telling him there wasn't
really anything wrong and he's looking
at my paperwork going this guy's got
leukemia and
he overrode her he raced me out of there
down to brooklyn methodist
and uh
the doctor
the charged physician the er physician
he says you're not leaving because uh
you're in a bad way and i said
what is it he said i need four you guys
i need i need a little while to figure
it out he goes but
you probably have one of a
few different types of leukemia he said
i'll drill into your hip take your
marrow and find out
and he said uh but in the meantime we'll
get the swelling on the spleen down like
some sort of rapid medicines and whatnot
because my spleen is about to rupture
i had no blood platelets left which is
your clotter so i basically would have
bled to death and uh
i found out from my team of doctors that
i had about 48 hours to live
um and that really set me off i was
infuriated because i was telling them
for a long time that i was sick
and
the doctors failed you the few doctors
in the beginning failed you i felt very
betrayed and and other guys had died
and uh i i had i had it out with that
one doctor i basically told her she was
fired from my case and she's
pretty politically
in charge person and i didn't care i i
jeopardized my my job for it because it
was my life and i got the sense that she
didn't really it didn't really matter to
her
she didn't have any empathy as you say
it was exact so why for her why for a
few others was there not a
a special care special compassion for
first of all all humans but
human beings in your position especially
a firefighter a first responder
you know alex i think what it is in the
department their title is just to get us
back to duty as quickly as possible when
we are either injured or sick because
what happens then is your replacement is
now in overtime
so you're out being paid on medical eve
but then they need to replace your spot
and then that costs more money
so i think it's just behooves them to
get as many
personnel back and especially during the
summer time you know they look at it
like oh maybe you want a few extra days
off to uh you know go to the beach
and uh
this one doctor he tipped his hand back
as if like i was drinking an alcohol
beverage he says hey busy summer because
i asked him to look at my spleen which
was sticking out of my abdomen like a
football
and i said excuse me sir i said how dare
you assume that i'm i'm abusing alcohol
because
you know alcohol abuse sometimes will
present itself as the spleen
is engorged than having an issue
so he automatically just assumed that
that was my situation wouldn't even give
me an exam
and i was horrified i was i was so angry
i mean i wanted to punch this guy out
and i literally was screaming at him and
and an executive officer came in to
defuse it
and sent me to another doctor and when i
showed her my paperwork she was
horrified she was like what did he say
and she said oh okay go go to your
regular doctor tomorrow who was one of
the department doctors and
and she just
it was just an indifference it was like
i don't know i i was shocked at the lack
of compassion but you know what that
being said i'm past it i you know it
life moves on
the team of doctors i i ended up with a
methodist and my subsequent oncologist
dr peter mincell
uh world class just incredible human
being my dr pete is just i love him i
just i love him like a friend like a big
brother like a father like a
uh my primary oncology care nurse mike
nunez was just incredible human being
and and he knew i was frightened because
i had to get two and a half years of
chemo uh compressed into seven days
or i was dead
these massive bags of chemo that never
stopped and
and uh
they they burned the minute the minute
they went into your body you felt like
you were burning to death from the
inside out
and mike when mike came in to hook me up
he said um
look i have to wear a hazmat suit this
stuff is so caustic that if it if it
drips it'll burn whenever it touches
and i was like but mike you're gonna put
that in my body how how the hell is it
not gonna kill me he says no no this is
exactly what it's supposed to do trust
me
so when he prepped the iv tube to get it
flowing it spilled onto the tube and the
tube started to smoke and burn
and i i went i said no f and way mike
you're not putting that in me no way no
way and he goes listen let me get
another one let me start it over and
here he is wearing a hazmat suit looking
at me and i'm going this is this is
insane
and he goes he looked at me he took my
hand and he says nils if you don't take
it you're dead
he says you got those three kids i i'm
sorry i have no other option you're dead
and i said all right mike okay and he
hooked me up
and you know what it was it was like
you know if you do drink alcohol and you
have like a shot or want you know strong
strong type spirit and you start feeling
that burn
well the minute he he hit me in the vein
it just started going up my arm burning
and then up my shoulder
across my neck
into my head across the rest of my body
within a minute down to my feet
and i was riding in pain for seven days
and i was praying to die
i was the seventh rescuer in six months
to come down with the rarest leukemia
there is there's only 500 cases in all
north america a year
and seven of us came down to six months
two guys died during treatment
seven responders police fire
two guys died in the first couple days
of the treatment because it's so vicious
your liver your heart your kidneys
something will fail
and i was praying and i was praying but
i wanted to die i was in so much pain
and i wouldn't take a painkiller because
i know people with some issues and i
just didn't want to go there
and
finally on the last day i gave i gave in
i said please i can't do this anymore i
was literally like jumping out of my
skin
and they gave me something
but it had burned out my mind it burned
out my body i couldn't hear i could
barely see it was vicious
but it worked
and
my nurses especially they just they were
so dedicated and devoted and i was not
an easy patient because i was in a lot
of pain it was it was bad
it was drove my friends my family crazy
it was just it wasn't good
but
on that first night
i had a quick vision of all these people
that i loved
that were dead that died a lot of them
in the trade center and i saw johnny i
saw i saw friends i grew up with
the last one was my my mother-in-law who
had passed six months before and she
died of
she was in a coma she had a stroke she
had a horrible
horrible last six months of life and she
wasn't fair because
she was so religious she went to church
every day devout catholic woman
and all of a sudden i see her and she's
smiling and
we used to talk a lot you know it's the
irish thing like the gab the gift to
give and uh
she used to call me a boyfriend because
we'd sit and talk for hours and talk
about books and about movies and about
food and i loved her she's my friend
and she'd say you know my boyfriend's
here and all of a sudden she's smiling
and she goes hi my boyfriend and i said
dad no no wait what are you doing she
goes he's not ready he doesn't want you
you got to go back got things to do
and i'm like no no no it hurts so much
please please take me and she left she
goes no no not yet i'll see you
and she just faded away
and one of my doctors on my team she she
was
she had she had a problem with religion
and that's okay i understand that you
know i'm not a i'm not a preacher i have
a faith but i don't preach it i don't
push it i just you know
live and let live
so she sent in this shrink to see me and
i and i was
messed up from the chemo but i i knew
what i was seeing i knew what i was
saying
and he was he was a jewish gentleman he
was a rabbi also in a synagogue and i
actually had responded in that district
and he he knew
114 would run into borough park oh yeah
i see tyler oh they come down the street
you know
and he asked me to tell him the story
and i did
and uh he started laughing and he scared
me now i said doc am i really crazy he
said no no
he said i believe you my friend he said
we we share the same god he goes we we
work in the same
corporation but in different departments
and he says
he says you did see your mother-in-law
he says your faith is that strong he
said i've had many patients express the
same sentiments he said so i want you to
listen to her and fight and be strong
and he said so what else do you want to
talk about i said well i don't know daca
my dad messed up he goes no no he goes
they're paying me for an hour it only
took 20 minutes so we watched the yankee
game together
but but it was just again it showed the
human condition here here's these two
men of two totally different faiths
and yet we shared that that bond of
faith and he had empathy and he had
sympathy
and he he's he saw
me and many other patients so he just
didn't assume and he and he gave me a
fair shake and i will always be grateful
to him for that
through any of this
the the pain you have to go through with
the leukemia but also the the days of 9
11 after
did your faith get challenged
you know
lexi was strange i it was times it was
so angry you know there's that range of
emotions the anger the denial the
depression the this to that
and this is the weirdest thing it was it
was mostly i knew my career was over
and uh they retired me out of the job
that that i got sick in august and that
october they told me i was out
and by the time i was processed and you
know used up my
my leaves and whatever you want to say
it was i was i was officially retired in
january of o2
and uh less than six months
and i'm there walking my dog one day my
rescue greyhound who i miss she was such
a soul god she lived to be almost 13
katie and
we were walking in the snow and i got
the call i was retired and i looked at
her and i'm like katie what am i gonna
do and she just looked up and said we're
gonna go on a lot more walks you know
and i was so sad and i was so sad i was
so angry because i lost my priesthood i
loved helping people i really alex i
would have done it for free
i would never tell mayor bloomberg that
right
it's all about the book right but like
you know honestly i would have i would
have been a new york city farmer i would
have paid them to do it yeah you know
and uh
i wasn't allowed anymore that's it you
have over 20 years and you have cancer
you know back when my dad got sick
they'd let you hang around for 10 12
years in an office but
not now now it's all about the bottom
line
and uh
but i was more depressed about losing a
job than almost losing my life like as
crazy as that sounds you know and it
just uh
it's more than a job i mean it's uh it's
a way of life man yeah it's also as your
family your father you're you're
carrying torture your father's oh my
friend i love my friends i love we work
24 hour shifts together you cook you
clean you break each other's jobs
relentlessly i mean it was i love those
guys so much i mean i i hope that my
kids and anyone that i know and care
about i hope they can experience the
bond
of that brotherhood that i experienced
in my life it was so god i i would give
anything to have it back just yeah
you